[Music]
so I've been playing a lot of drums now
that I don't have any vices left I mean
I do oh by the way some [ __ ] [ __ ]
sent me an email about that that
documentary game-changers and he's goes
now you got to watch the the [ __ ] Joe
Rogan podcast cuz he had those guys on
and then the guy kind of clarifies what
he meant and it's just like this should
be a [ __ ] law against first of all
poisoning food which i don't understand
in this whole [ __ ] war against terror
why you can give [ __ ] to cows that
people then give to their kids that
there's so many [ __ ] hormones that
that little girls are getting their
periods at ten years of age little girls
are getting their period ten eleven
[ __ ] years old because of the amount
of hormones that these [ __ ] companies
have put into [ __ ] cows that ends up
in the milk that children are drinking
okay and they get less [ __ ] for that
than a [ __ ] stand-up comedian who
sends out a [ __ ] tweet meanwhile
they're sitting there telling me that
they're fighting [ __ ] terrorism we're
for the last 30 years I have to drink
bottled water because of all this [ __ ]
corporations they basically poisoned our
own [ __ ] water supply isn't what
doesn't wouldn't Isis love to do both of
those things [ __ ] with their food supply
and our water supply why aren't those
people considered terrorists why is it
like putting [ __ ] opioids or opiates
whatever the [ __ ] you call them Oh like
pharmaceutical companies the amount of
deaths that they caused not a Caitlyn
Jenner joke raked over the [ __ ] coals
figure that one out it's all about that
[ __ ] money that's what it's about
right Jesus Christ am i this [ __ ] old
I'm this old now that I don't I have no
[ __ ] vices and I'm talking about rap
it up Jesus Christ bill you're on the
12th hole okay oh by the way have you
seen this this [ __ ] Bloomberg might
join the [ __ ] race here I gotta tell
you for the first time in a long time
that actually made me excited about
politics just as far as the matchup a
billionaire versus a billionaire you
know they're claiming they're using
their own money which is [ __ ]
hilarious because I don't think you
became a billionaire by spending
hundreds of millions of dollars to go
going for a job that pays four five
hundred grand a year all right unless
unless the reason why these lunatic
billionaires Donald Trump and [ __ ]
Michael Bloomberg he said his first
thing
Bloomberg those two [ __ ] guys I think
that will they want that job because of
all of their other businesses in the
[ __ ] red tape that they can get rid
of for their businesses businesses that
they can get rid of by being in that
five hundred grand a year [ __ ] job
that's my only other theory cuz other
than that why would you want that job
we have never-ending Wars we're
consistently dropping bombs that [ __ ]
innocent people end up dying you have to
make the decision do we go in here do we
go in there is that a group of
terrorists and then it turns out to be a
wedding or whatever the [ __ ] happened
over there and you got to [ __ ] live
with that then you're gonna age in
[ __ ] dog years and you're gonna make
five hundred grand a year and you're a
[ __ ] billionaire let me ask you this
okay let's all let's all play armchair
[ __ ] detectives here what is the
motivation all right
don't even tell me that you [ __ ]
patriotic because the way billionaires
run their business has nothing to do
with America it has to do all with the
[ __ ] money and then blaming the
shareholders well
you know we do is what the shareholders
[ __ ] room where we move it all right